Rubin report presidents week with five
shows in five days on five former
presidents of the United States in
partnership with learn.
Liberty continues today and joining me
now is a professor of history at Western
Connecticut State University and author
of James Madison and the making of
America.
Kevin got made.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
I'm happy to be here.
I'm excited to talk to you because this
is big because you are both an expert in
James Madison and Thomas Jefferson.
Now everyone that's watching this knows
that Thomas Jefferson is my favorite
founder.
I'm going to give you a little room here
to play and by the end,
see if you can convince me that James
Madison should be my favorite founder.
Oh,
well,
I'm not sure I want to play that game
because actually the reason I wrote a
book about Madison is because over time
I had come to think that his reputation
was generally exaggerated among scholars
that although he did very important
things and I think he should be
remembered,
he wasn't as important as people were
remembering him as having been.
In fact,
in this,
he's similar to Alexander Hamilton who
doesn't deserve all the accolades he's
received from the musical Hamilton.
Oh my.
Well,
you're shooting everywhere
now.
I'm saying they were admirable people,
but there's a tendency among biographers
to make their guys the central guys.
So Hamilton becomes the greatest
American ever.
Madison becomes the smartest man ever.
You don't.
You don't need to do that.
If you make him the real fellow,
he's still extremely interesting and
important.
All right?
And I think that really is what your
book is about,
making him the real value in showing
some of the flaws and some of the
mistakes he made along the way.
And we're gonna get into all of that.
So let's just start at the beginning.
What should we know about James
Madison's childhood?
Ah,
well,
Madison was born.
He was the first child of the most
important man in his county,
which was Piedmont Virginia,
Orange County in those days,
the Piedmont region,
which is the area just off the coast of
Virginia,
just out of tidewater,
was the western most extent of European
settlement.
And his father,
James Madison senior,
was the wealthiest man in the county.
He was the largest land holder.
He was the largest slave holder.
He was the county lieutenant,
which means he was the commander of the
county militia.
He was ahead of the vestry,
which means he was the head of the lay
organization that ran the county,
a parish of the established church.
He was just the most important person.
What this meant for James Madison junior
was he was set.
He was going to inherit all of that.
He was going to be able to have the kind
of education that virtually nobody else
in Orange County would get.
In fact,
he's maybe the only person in his cohort
of Virginians who went off to Princeton
to college.
Most people would go to the colonial
college in Virginia,
William and Mary far inferior
institution in those days to Princeton.
We could talk about whether it still is
today.
That's probably a different show.
That is a different show.
It's,
it's an interesting question.
Um,
but anyway,
and James Madison Junior,
because of his tie to his father and his
father's eminent place ended up having
a,
not only a more elite kind of education,
but also a different outlook when it
came to human nature,
the relationship between government and
individuals,
individual rights and especially what I
think is the area in which he was most
important.
Freedom of religion than other people.
Yeah.
And he was key in making sure that
separation of church and state was part
of the US Constitution.
Everything that's were we're going to
get to all that.
Do we know anything about his father's
politics or even just with even
interested in politics when he was
young?
There are,
there wasn't what we would call politics
in colonial Virginia.
There were,
there weren't parties,
there wasn't kind of party division.
Essentially.
People were uh,
more or less all the same elite group.
They had a common interest.
Virtually everybody who lived in
Virginia was either tobacco grower,
a slave on tobacco plantation,
somebody who lived in.
It's a small town that's the only kind
of towns there were in Virginia and sold
tobacco or was a lawyer who worked for
tobacco farmers notice a common theme
here.
So because people had a very similar
kind of economic life,
they didn't have the kind of political
division we think of as normal.
It's interesting.
It almost,
it sorta sounds pre politics all
together.
They were just sort of local and you
kinda had to do what you did.
Yes,
pretty much.
That's really interesting.
So he goes off to school and is this
where he starts becoming more political?
Yes.
Well what happened was he went off to
school in New Jersey and unlike William
and Mary,
which was Episcopalian,
the established Church of Virginia was
the Church of England.
Is that one of the reasons he didn't
want to go there because we're going to
get into a little more about his
feelings about religion,
but obviously he wanted to go to a
bigger school,
but was it also very much about the
religious school?
Well,
we don't have any indication that that
had anything to do with it.
It seems that the reason he went off to
New Jersey was because of the very crude
state of scientific knowledge in those
days.
So if like James Madison Junior,
who remains the smallest man who's ever
been president,
if you had what he called a sickly
constitution,
than you would want to avoid the vapors
around Williamsburg.
People thought there was something in
the air that made you sick and they had
no idea of mosquito born illnesses or
any anything to do with sanitation.
So he went off to New Jersey because he
was afraid he'd get sick if he went to
Williamsburg,
which is on the James near the coast.
And so,
um,
it was kind of fortuitous that he ended
up at Princeton under the tutelage of
somebody who was a minister,
but not an episcopalian.
And so were episcopalians at the time
had a kind of latitude and area in a
very liberal religious understanding of
people's motives and people's
personality.
And so on.
If you had gone to Princeton and studied
under John Witherspoon,
who would also be a signer of the
declaration of independence in time,
uh,
you would have been under the tutelage
of somebody who was a presbyterian.
That is somebody who took calvinism.
Seriously.
Somebody who thought men were naturally
corrupt,
somebody who was skeptical of the
motives of other people and taught that
this is the way a Christian should
understand human psychology.
And so if you think about,
if you're familiar with and think about
Madison's key political writings,
for example,
famous federalist number,
51 where he says if men were angels,
no government would be necessary,
but until we're governed by angels,
let ambition counteract ambition.
That sounds like John Witherspoon.
He wouldn't have been saying that if he
had gone to school at William and Mary.
Interesting.
So a lot of his individualism was really
born there.
Yeah.
And the funny thing about that is
though,
that although the various elements of
what I've been saying have to do with
weather spoons,
religion,
and the religion of Princeton,
generally madison was not in a
Presbyterian.
We have very limited information about
what Madison's own personal religious
beliefs were,
but it happened that he came back to
Virginia and within a couple of years
there was serious.
There was one of the intermittent waves
of persecution of non episcopalians and
then he ended up in a correspondence
with a fellow he had known at Princeton.
This guy was from,
from Pennsylvania,
so he had gone back home to
Pennsylvania,
like New Jersey had been founded by
quakers and so never had any kind of
established church.
Quakers disbelieved in established
churches.
So Madison ends up writing to this
friend of his from Princeton who's in
Philadelphia and saying,
Oh,
I'm ashamed of what's going on here in
a.
In a nearby county.
We have half a dozen men who are in
jail.
He said,
close jail for no other offense than
just preaching the Gospel.
Teaching people the Baptist
understanding of a spiritual reality,
and of course that was illegal in
Virginia.
So they were thrown in jail.
Madison in this fellow.
Then think through the question,
well,
how ot government to be involved in the
individual's religious lives and the
conclusion that Madison came to was,
it shouldn't.
That is he thought and he was going to
come to this conclusion and helping to
write the first American Declaration of
Rights to the Virginia Declaration of
rights of 1776 that the traditional
English liberal and in Anglo American
liberal position on religion,
which is we should have toleration in
England.
They had a rule that you could be any
kind of Protestant you wanted,
which sounds very,
very oppressive to us.
Slim version of the thing is though that
in the context in the 18th century,
if you were French,
you had to be a catholic.
If you are Turkish,
you had to be a Muslim.
If you were in England and you were not
an episcopalian,
you couldn't be in the House of Lords or
couldn't be in the House of Commons.
You couldn't go to Oxford or Cambridge,
but in general the English role was
we'll tolerate you.
We won't punish you for not being an
Episcopalian.
So that's not like France or Spain or or
Turkey and I'm Madison,
ends up with this idea that toleration
isn't enough and so when they're
drafting the Virginia Declaration of
Rights,
the first American bill of rights,
the committee version of a religious
article of the declaration of Rights of
said Virginians will be entitled to the
fullest toleration matters of religion.
That was George Mason's formulation.
He was a very liberal fellow when it
came to these questions.
And Madison,
age 25,
the youngest man in the room says,
I disapprove of this.
I think that toleration implies that the
government one knows more than the
individual to is in a supervisory role
over the individual.
And I think these are both incorrect
ideas.
The government should just stay out of
these things.
So Madison said,
I propose an alternative that we should
say Virginia's are entitled to the Free
Exercise of religion.
And when Mason heard this explanation,
he said,
I endorse this.
And then the committee,
the whole convention voted and they
voted unanimously for Madison is
formulation.
So in my book I say,
and this is not a common view,
I say,
I think this is the most important thing
madison ever did.
He came up with this idea that
government should,
should not be telling people what to
think about the afterlife,
about religious ethics,
about what church to attend.
It shouldn't say we're going to be
tolerant of you if you're wrong,
but we're going to have our own right
views as was going on in England.
And he would of course later be the one
who ensured that this phrase,
ology free exercise will be in the
federal constitution.
Gosh,
you gave me a lot to work with.
They're so.
It's such an.
It's such an interesting point though,
that you're making,
because we talked so much about
tolerance these days and he was saying
back then,
no,
tolerance isn't enough.
We need,
we need true freedom.
Here was he really worked through that
easy.
I mean everyone,
George Mason and everybody heard it and
that quickly or like,
yeah,
they agreed to include it in the
declaration of rights and they agreed as
soon as,
as they got to this question of
formulating their own new form of
government during the revolution,
they agreed that they would discontinue
taxing people to support the Anglican
Church,
the episcopal church,
but it was going to be a long struggle
to have formal this establishment of the
Church of England in Virginia.
So Madison was central to that too.
He and Jeff Jefferson wrote a bill
called the Virginia statutes religious
freedom now,
but he proposed it.
It was defeated Madison 10 years later
ensured that an alternative taxing
people to support whatever form of
Christianity you wanted would be
defeated.
And then he brushed off Jefferson's bill
and said,
we need,
we need to pass this.
So it happened.
Virginia became the first officially
secular society ever anywhere.
It's really incredible.
So he was 25 when he started this.
So how old are you?
What I done?
I'm 41.
I'm 54 and I've done nothing right.
The Madison came up with this one.
If he had dropped dead when he was 25,
he would still be one of the 10 most
important American.
Yeah,
it is incredible,
but it's such as we're going to get to
all the other things.
He did that through line to all the
freedoms that we have right now.
You briefly said that we don't know much
about his actual religious beliefs.
Do we know anything actually because
there's.
There seems to be this debate these days
about what they want.
Most of the founders actually believed
because you know,
they were talking about rights from God
and yet so many of them obviously
Madison but Jefferson included and
others were also so it was so important
to talk about a separation of church and
state where they all just deists do we
have a sense of,
have any insight into that?
Well,
we have information about some people,
but the term founders is very nebulous.
What do you mean by that?
That's the problem.
So often people say,
well,
all the founders believed this and
they're talking about six guys or eight
guys.
My,
uh,
my own view is that that term should be
understood to include people who signed
the declaration of independence,
who were involved in Philadelphia
Convention and writing the constitution
who were in the ratification conventions
and agreed to the constitution who were
in the congress that proposed the bill
of rights,
uh,
who were involved in the debate about
whether to adopt the bill of rights.
So I use that term far more broadly and
if you understand the term broadly as
I've just been most,
most overwhelmingly Americans were very
religious in general.
They were evangelical Christians and so
they did not have this kind of,
um,
to each his own attitude about these
things that Madison or Jefferson did
so,
so in an interesting way was their
reasoning for church and state to be
separated.
Not so much that they were anti religion
but,
but the,
but because they saw the way religion
was so intertwined with,
you know,
the monarchy and the government back in
England without.
Was that really the key of it?
It wasn't necessarily an anti religious
stance.
Well,
it wasn't only in England.
Madison wrote a,
a,
a pamphlet.
I'm in the seventies and eighties called
memorial and remonstrance against
religious assessments and there he was
answering that proposal I mentioned
before for having a general tax in
Virginia to support the Christian
congregation of one's choice.
Right?
So Patrick Henry had said,
we've had a decline in morals in
Virginia during the war.
We want to resuscitate them in one way
to have that happen would be to return
to a situation in which people actually
go to church,
which they support a church,
so we're going to say not that you have
to support the church of England
anymore,
but you have to choose something.
You have to choose one and designated.
And so Madison in response to this,
among other things,
wrote a pamphlet called Memorial
remonstrance against religious
assessments where he argued against
having the government support any
religion at all.
And his grounds for making that argument
was that this had been a harmful.
A tendency of governments forever.
Right?
So it wasn't only in England,
it wasn't only particular time.
He argued that it had been harmful to
people into societies in general,
wherever it had been tried,
which was essentially everywhere.
And he wanted that to stop.
Do we know anything about what they all
thought this whole crew,
whether you count the founders as the
six to eight or sort of the broader
group that you're talking,
that they really
realized how important the work they
were doing was?
Sure.
Yeah.
Actually,
it's funny,
although a John Adams in Massachusetts
and Thomas Jefferson in Virginia didn't
know each other at the time.
Each of them when he was very young man
wrote a letter in which he closed by
saying,
save this letter.
People are gonna.
Want to read my letters?
Jefferson was a teenager when he,
when he said that,
and by the time he died,
68 years later,
I'm 67,
something like that.
By the time he died,
he'd saved over 30,000
documents he'd written and the same John
Adams and attorney writing to his
beloved Abigail Smith.
Later Abigail Adams said,
saved this letter.
People don't want to read my letters.
And actually people like Jefferson
Madison and Alexander Hamilton,
Washington,
they saved all their documents.
They saved all their notes.
They had the idea that what they were
doing was really important and they also
had the idea that there was inadequate
information about the,
the fundamental commitments and
decisions of most other societies.
So they wanted to make a record.
It's just fascinating to think about it.
It's truly before the birth of a nation
and we're doing this in places where
they couldn't tweet at each other or get
on the phone with each other and I
haven't really figured this well.
If they have been able to tweet,
they wouldn't have written much.
Right.
So that's the thing,
you know now,
I mean,
I feel kind of sorry as a historian of
late 18th,
early 19th centuries for people who want
to work on contemporary stuff because
we've seen.
I mean,
even if the law says save all your
emails,
you might find $60,000
and just disappeared.
You know,
who knows what happened in.
And the plan is that nobody will ever
read that.
Right?
Well,
of course the special council found it,
but for most people I have a feeling
that just,
just reams of this stuff is trashed and
that means future historians have no
information.
They're going to have a cascade of stuff
and there are big libraries full of
books,
but most of the secret things we'd
actually like to be able to read that
went into their decision making.
They've intentionally wrecked.
That's why there's such richness to
this,
you know,
hundred year period or so.
Um,
do we know anything about who the other
formative people were around him?
Who were the other people that really
influenced his ideas?
Ah,
well,
there are people he read,
but a witherspoon is in a place for him,
like William Small,
who was a professor at William and Mary,
who had the most influence on Jefferson.
And then Madison had particular past
writers who were really influential with
him.
One was the borrower and a French
political scientist who wrote a book
called the law,
the spirit of the laws in which he
examined Roman history in British
history and tried to deduce rules of
political science.
So Madison carefully considered,
wants,
excuse writing,
and adopted some of it as his own and
then morphed other parts of it so that
you couldn't recognize them as having
come from Montesquieu.
But you can see that the influence of
bunch of skin is very significant for
him.
So that's,
that's one example there Sir William
Blackstone and who was a leading,
uh,
English legal thinker was influential
virtually across the spectrum of
American legal and political thought
that Jefferson said negative things
about him,
but he was influenced by him anyway.
Besides that,
historians,
Greek and Roman writers,
you know,
if you have little kids reading the
ceased to see spot run,
they're going to learn that when they're
a little bit,
if you have little kids reading about
cincinnatus and his is a short lived
dictatorship in Rome and,
and a renunciation of dictatorial
authority at the end of the war,
then they're going to learn that kind of
thing when they're little a.
So this is one reason why I think see
spot run is very harmful to people.
You know,
even if we're,
we have our youngest children learning
to read that way.
We might think,
well,
that's the best way to have the kid come
out with a 3000 word vocabulary,
but when he gets through he hasn't
learned.
He doesn't know anything.
So.
So,
uh,
the point was that there are,
there are a few roman historians and
Greek historians when we can see having
influenced virtually all of these
people.
They were all influenced.
Now,
I'm sorry,
they were all educated by learning Greek
learning,
Latin,
reading the Greek poets,
reading the Roman poets,
reading the Greek historians,
Roman historians,
Greek philosophers.
They actually argue about which Greek
philosophers they like and don't like.
And so can you imagine,
you know,
let's have a debate between,
I don't know,
Joe Biden and Mitt Romney over your
favorite Roman historian.
Yeah.
So,
so we just know nowadays people who are
quote unquote educated,
even in our supposedly finest
institutions,
they don't come out of it knowing much.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's why I like asking these questions
because it's like,
wow,
these guys really were the thinkers of
their time to read all the intellectual
work to become the people they are
versus now.
I mean,
and it just happened that the,
the educational establishment of their
time was pumping stuff into their brains
that would be not only useful for
politicians,
but also useful to make a man,
a good man,
to help him decide what good meant,
to help him decide how he might follow
that path.
And today again,
I think,
uh,
the education system of which I'm part
is kind of void of this consideration
even
we do.
We could probably do a whole show on
that.
Obviously.
We talk a lot about the education system
in general here.
You mentioned his wife briefly.
What else do we have to know about his
personal life as he's somewhere in his
twenties now,
before we get to all the other stuff?
Well,
James Madison was slight.
He was reserved.
He was quiet.
There are various people who met him and
said he was unattractive.
He was not good in a group.
So he ended up in,
when he was in his thirties,
he had a kind of flirtation,
which apparently became serious,
at least on his end with a much younger
woman.
And,
uh,
it seems from his cryptic statements to
Jefferson that maybe he was planning and
engagement and then that fell through
and then later on we all know of Dolly
Madison,
who was a widow whom he ended up
marrying.
She had been married and had children,
one of whom had died.
And then she had a surviving son.
The two of them were married for very
long time.
People who saw them together,
so they seem very happy somehow.
They never had any offspring,
so we,
I guess were left to deduce that more
likely than not,
he was physically incapable,
but we don't know that.
Um,
but in any event,
he didn't have any fiscal offspring.
What about the nature of his friendship
with Thomas Jefferson?
Because they,
they definitely had a lot in common,
but there was definitely stark
differences as well.
Right?
Well,
they had,
they had quite a lot in common.
I think nowadays it's interesting for
scholars to ponder the extent to which
they were divergent.
And I think if either of them recognize
the divergence that was more Madison who
realized that they weren't exactly a
like,
can we just briefly,
let's do some of the things that they
basically agreed on.
Okay.
Well what did they agree on?
What they agreed on?
Republicanism.
They agreed on freedom of conscience.
They agreed that the state and the
church shouldn't be related.
They agreed that in general you'd like
to have a nowadays what we call a non
interventionist foreign policy because
that had all kinds of,
or I should say that the opposite of a
non interventionist foreign policy would
have all kinds of negative political,
philosophical,
social,
economic consequences.
So both of them agreed where possible
stay of wars where possible just have
free trade,
don't,
don't try to jigger your economy and
your network of trade relationships to,
to favor yourself.
And,
and uh,
the two of them agreed about a monarchy
and how harmful it had been over time
and various European countries and that,
that was to be avoided.
So these are the main things.
And I think also,
although I said before,
we don't have good proof of Madison's
own religious commitments,
Jefferson was one who you may know
people like this who didn't have,
who didn't have any friends who
disagreed with him about major
questions,
you know,
somebody like Madison or John Marshall
or John Randolph of roanoke or some
other contemporaries of theirs had
friends with whom they had market
disagreements.
But Jefferson.
No.
So it's very much against my ethos.
Yeah,
you're moving.
So I think the thing is that,
uh,
um,
at least in so far as Jefferson
understood it,
they must have been pretty close when it
came to these kinds of questions.
So what were those divergent?
Well,
Jefferson was a more radical thinker.
He was less trepidatious about trying
the novel,
about overthrowing the established.
So for example,
he wrote that he thought that every
constitution should be void after 19
years.
Well,
Madison had played the key role in
writing the US Constitution.
He thought had been a near run thing.
At one point he said he thought it was a
miracle by which he meant it was very
unlikely that you'd end up with any kind
of agreement in Philadelphia in the
summer of 17,
87,
let alone that will be ratified by all
13 states within,
you know,
three years.
So he didn't,
he didn't want to try that again.
For Jefferson and the,
the practical pragmatic question of
whether this was feasible was less an
issue than,
well,
is it a good idea?
Is this what we should do?
Do we want to be able to say that you
have literal consent from everybody
every once in a while.
And so where did the 19 years.
Well,
he,
Jefferson had come,
had calculated that had a generation,
was more or less 19 years.
So he thought that if you had an end to
every constitution every 19 years,
then every person who lived in a,
a,
you know,
a kind of a standard,
a lifespan would have least once or
twice when he was involved in agreeing
to a constitution,
agreeing to a political system.
And in general,
you should live under a political system
to which you had agreed,
but nowadays we have the idea that,
well,
okay,
society in general,
Americans agreed to the US Constitution
even though you didn't.
And I didn't.
Uh,
I guess if you're an immigrant,
you have to agree to it.
But,
uh,
if you're born here,
you don't.
And that Jefferson thought this was a
problem and we want to avoid this,
we need to figure a way around it from
Addison.
Don't talk about that.
This was really hard to do,
you know,
and it's not likely it'll be better if
we try to remake it.
So
he's feeling they're really.
That we would sort of forget about the
freedoms that we started with and that
every generation would kind of forget
and we'd sort of keep wiggling.
Well,
there was that too,
actually.
He said at one point,
I wish I could recall the exact words,
but he said something like,
from the moment the revolution ends will
be on the decline.
Right?
So his feeling was that people's
attentiveness to these questions of
political legitimacy,
the proper structure of government,
the extent to which an individual's
humanity ought to be respected by the
system and society,
the acuteness of people's awareness of
these things would immediately drop off
and then we'd continue to drop off.
And so how do you prevent that from
ending in?
Well,
the people in government pay attention
to.
Nobody else does.
Periodically you have a new constitution
to create it.
You have to go through the whole process
again.
Everybody's going to be involved,
it'll be a hot topic.
And so for Madison this is speculative
and wow,
this could have really bad results.
So
Huh.
It's interesting because I think you can
make probably really strong arguments on
either side of that.
So this must have really been a point
for the two of them.
Yeah,
they,
they disagreed about it in print and in
writing.
Yeah.
So James Madison wrote,
I mean there's so much stuff that either
he was directly writing,
like the federalist papers that he was
editing and zillion other things.
Is this a good point to talk about the
federalist papers we need to live up you
want.
Is there anything else we should lead
up?
Let me just say about them in general
that they are highly.
Their influences.
Highly exaggerated in the general
understanding.
Really the.
Yes,
because I told got a bottle of wine
that's called the federalists Madison's
picture on.
It's a standard issue,
a silhouette of Madison.
I.
I is celebrate the person who designed
the logo,
but the thing is among those of us who
are specialists in this area,
there's a kind of consensus that the
federalist did not persuade.
We cannot prove.
We cannot identify one person who was
persuaded to vote yes in a ratification
convention because he read the
federalist and was persuaded.
So in other words,
the idea that you're kind of taught in
eighth grade and then in high school,
you know,
and then law school if to do that is
well,
here are these.
Here are these papers that were used to
go out and get the people to support the
constitution.
That was their purpose,
but we don't know that they did and in
fact by the time the last of them was
published,
that is by the time the last of them was
seen by anybody anywhere.
Eight states had already ratified the
constitution,
so clearly our eight states that weren't
persuaded by at least those last ones,
and then there were all.
There were some states where none of
them were published in any of the
newspapers and there was no state other
than New York where they were all
published besides which in New York.
It was not the federalists that persuade
people to ratify the constitution.
We know that for a fact.
Well,
what happened was that by the time in
New York came around to considering and
it okay,
well maybe people don't know,
but the constitution says in article
seven that the constitution will go into
effect among the ratifying states.
As soon as nine states have ratified,
whether there were 13.
So as soon as two thirds of the states
have ratified,
and what that meant was that each state
was supposed to have like a state
legislative election,
except it would be an election just for
delegates to this convention that would
decide one question.
Do we agree yes or no to the
constitution?
So by the time New York,
uh,
met,
um,
oh,
there were already there.
We're already a eight states that
ratified the constitution.
Then Wild New York convention was
meeting New Hampshire.
Ratified that made nine in Virginia.
Did that,
made 10 New York was going to be 11th.
Then when they had their election in New
York state for delegates to the
ratification convention,
two thirds of them were people who had
promised a vote for me and I'll vote no
in the convention.
But when they had the convention,
um,
they got word while they're out at that
New Hampshire had agreed that made nine.
So now it's going to go into effect.
Then they heard Virginia had that made
10.
Now it's really going to go into effect
because George Washington can be the
president.
Right?
And so that leaves us North Carolina and
Rhode Island.
Well,
if we stay out,
we're going to have an independent
country of New York,
North Carolina,
Rhode Island,
and then the federalists from New York
City had a newspaper published an
article that said in case New York votes
no on ratification,
New York City will succeed from New York
state and joined the Union as a state.
So then you'd have the independent
country of upstate New York.
And at that point the one of the leading
anti federalists and the convention made
a speech in which he said,
we don't have a choice.
Now we have to vote.
Yes.
So notice I didn't mention the
federalist and this whole discussion,
right.
Had nothing to do with it.
That's really fascinating.
Because I was going to ask you at before
you started answering,
I was gonna ask you well with the states
that had said no,
would they have had any recourse.
But basically you're saying their own.
Yeah.
Actually by the time George Washington
was inaugurated president in April of
17,
89,
there were 11 states that are read by
the constitution.
So there were 22 senators that are 11
states represented in the House of
Representatives.
Two of the 13 states were independent
countries,
North Carolina and Rhode Island,
and they were treated as independent
countries.
And eventually they talked in Congress
about.
The question was,
well,
what should we do about the fact that
Rhode Island won't join the Union?
Maybe we should cut off trade with Rhode
Island and make it a little little dot
on North American map that doesn't have
fridge.
Yeah.
At any way.
Finally,
because,
well,
what else are we going to do?
Rhode Island agreed to the constitution,
but when they first had their election
in Rhode Island about instead of having
an election for ratification convention,
as soon as the Philadelphia convention
ended and said,
okay,
here you need to ratify the
constitution,
become a member of the union.
Rhode Island had a referendum on should
we have an election for a convention?
And they voted like 90 percent.
No,
we don't even want to vote on whether to
vote.
No,
we just know.
Wow.
And so when they finally got around to
having a,
um,
most people were overwhelmingly opposed
to it,
but they finally ended up agreeing to it
because what else are we going to do?
The other 12 states are already in the
United States and besides that are
staying out means they're talking about
things like creating the judicial
system,
recommending a bill of rights.
Rhode Island's got no congressman,
they're not participating in any of
this.
They're going to end up in the union
anyway.
So they finally joined.
Again,
this has nothing to do with the
federalist papers.
I still want to get great version of the
But what have been the argument for
people saying no at that point?
I guess,
I mean,
in Rhode Island.
Yeah.
Well,
um,
during the,
uh,
this is gonna be hard for people who are
listening to understand,
but in the 18th century,
if you said money,
like when I say money and you think of
an image in your mind,
money,
uh,
that's not what they thought of.
I thought of gold and silver coins,
right?
What that's called Specie.
And what they had begun to do in Rhode
Island was print notes Bay,
what were called bank notes.
We get paper money and a printing.
This notes is just a way to inflate your
way out of debt.
And so there were a lot of debtors in
Rhode Island who liked this printing
money and getting them out of debt.
So they just kept voting for people in
the legislature who would do this?
Well,
the constitution said that a state could
not make anything but gold or silver
currency.
So in other words,
if you joined the union,
you can't keep printing money.
Rhode Island had this paper money party
that was not going to agree to this.
Yeah,
that's why they put it off forever.
Interesting.
90 17.
90 was when they joined the union.
Yeah,
it's over a year after Washington was
inaugurated.
Alright.
So I want to do the eighth grade version
has of the federalist papers.
That's why I want to circle back there
for a second.
Okay.
That's really fascinating.
And I don't think most people know that,
that they didn't have the influence that
we now believe them to have.
So for the eighth grade version of this,
really,
he was just trying to get people on
board signing the constitution.
That was,
that was the general idea.
But what actually was in there,
was it a real sales pitch?
People that just really don't know.
Okay.
What's a know about the federal?
Actually the people who you keep saying
the federalist papers,
and I keep seeing the federalists,
the term,
the title,
the federalists papers was not given to
this document until 1961.
Originally it was just called the
federalists author was Publius,
which was a pseudonym for John Jay.
James Madison and Alexander Hamilton.
Um,
they wrote different essays.
There are two or three where we think
probably Hamilton cooperative.
Yeah.
But anyway,
so that was the only thing that was the
compilation.
So they put them all together and it's,
it's one series under the pseudonym.
Nobody will not make that error.
But the,
uh,
the purpose of the series was that
Hamilton lived in New York and he knew,
as I mentioned a few minutes ago,
that they had their election for a
ratification convention in New York.
And two thirds of the people they
elected voted no so or promised to vote
no on the convention.
So what do we do about this?
I'm at the Philadelphia Convention.
Hamilton had been one of three delegates
from New York.
The other two left.
After a few weeks they gave speeches in
which they explained we were sent here
to propose amendments to the articles of
confederation,
not create a new government.
One of the two who left was the chief
justice of New York.
And when they got home to New York,
the governor of New York was entirely
against this.
Right?
He agreed with them entirely.
We're not going to have a new
constitution.
We don't want any of this stuff.
We don't want to transfer a lot of
authority out of New York.
And so no,
we're against it.
So Hamilton knew that most people in New
York,
political establishment didn't like it.
They had elections voted against it.
What are we going to do?
Well,
maybe I could go directly to the people.
So his idea was to have a series of
newspaper essays maybe to get voters to
change their minds.
I'm not going to persuade the governor
or the chief justice.
They're both definitely set,
but maybe through a newspaper series we
could get people to change their minds.
So it's kind of interesting.
He,
he went to a friend of his name,
Gouverneur Morris,
the guy who actually wrote the
constitution.
So if you think of the expression,
the actual constitution,
you see that fancy Henry Gouverneur
Morris,
his handwriting.
He was one of the delegates from New
York and Philadelphia Convention,
I mean from Pennsylvania in the
Philadelphia Convention,
and he wrote the constitution.
Hamilton asked Morris,
will you please help me write this
series of essays for the papers to
persuade New Yorkers is part of the
constitution.
And Morris said not,
don't write for newspapers.
So then he went to another friend of his
former congressman named William durer
and he said,
would you please write some essays?
So Dora wrote three essays that were
going to be in this series in Hamilton,
read them and said,
now these aren't good enough.
So dual,
republished them as a separate pamphlet.
And then he talked to John.
Jay.
John Jay was actually probably the most
famous New Yorker at the time,
and Jay said,
yes,
I'll do it.
But after he wrote a couple of them,
he got extremely sick.
He was bedridden for weeks,
and so he ended up writing only five of
the 85 essays.
So now Hamilton's now what?
And it turned out that this,
this,
a Virginian congressman who had been in
the Philadelphia convention,
Madison was back in New York City where
Congress was meeting.
He was a member of Congress too.
And he asked Madison,
will you help me write these for the
newspapers?
I got to do something in Madison,
said,
sure,
I'll do it.
So that's why Madison ends up being kind
of second most important author of the
series.
Um,
the thing about the series is in my book
on Madison,
James Madison and making America,
I devote a lot of space to the
federalist,
not because it was important at the
time,
but for two reasons.
One,
it's important now.
People tend to,
even people in Congress,
the presidents of people who are on
federal courts,
they tend to start to answer the
question,
how do you understand the constitution
by saying,
well,
here's what federalist 48 says.
You know,
so that's one thing,
but another thing is that this is one of
the most important things Madison did.
Even if he,
even if no one had read them their
brilliance.
So you know,
if you have a painter,
you writing a book about a painter and
he made a brilliant painting and nobody
saw it until last week.
You'd have a chapter on it because it's
important.
It's an interesting part of his life.
So I think the fact that Madison was as
brilliant political scientists sheds
light on the rest of his career.
He had an extremely important political
career besides his career in the short
lived career as a political scientist.
So that's why I paid them a lot of
attention.
But the point is,
and I said before,
I wrote this book about Madison,
partly because we thought is his
significance has been exaggerated in
several ways.
One is the federalists didn't,
didn't sell the constitution actually in
the play Hamilton,
fascinating.
And the play Hamilton,
there's a song,
but you know,
you sold it,
you wrote it,
and all this stuff about Hamilton,
which is also totally exaggerated.
Uh,
but the same thing goes for Hamilton,
you know,
the same series.
It didn't,
it didn't sell it.
It's not true.
They didn't make people ratify the
constitution,
the two of them.
All right,
well now that you've changed the lore of
the federalist or the federalist papers,
depending on what year we're talking
that we're referencing them,
right?
Let's talk about some of the other
things that he drafted.
So he actually did draft the
constitution and the bill of rights.
I think people are very confused what
that actually means or how many people
actually did this together,
where they all sitting in a room where
they mailing pieces back and forth.
Were they sending edits to people?
How did the whole process actually go?
Oh,
well,
you mean you want to start with us
constantly.
Let's start with the constitution.
Okay.
So Madison is often called the father of
the constitution.
I think this is exaggerated.
So did he,
in his own lifetime,
people gave him accolades like that and
he would always reject them.
In fact,
at one point he said the,
uh,
the constitution was the work of many
hands heads and many hands.
And what he meant by that was that the
constitution was largely unlike what he
had proposed.
So,
uh,
essentially he had an idea and he wasn't
the only one.
He was part of a movement in 17,
seventies and eighties called the
federalists movement,
which is kind of confusing because we
have different groups in American
history are called federalists.
There's going to be a federalist party,
not the same people.
Who were the federalists who were behind
creating the US Constitution.
Who were that?
Were those original?
Well,
the,
these.
Okay.
The Labor Party is the one that congeals
around Alexander Hamilton in 17 counties
over his,
uh,
his platform,
his program,
his treasury secretary in the Washington
ministration.
But before that,
there had been people who wanted to
strengthen the central government in 17,
seventies and the eighties.
They're called federalists too.
You have Hamilton,
Madison,
uh,
Richard Morris,
who is the chief financial expert in the
continental congress in the Secretary
for finance of the Confederation
Congress,
the guy who has to pay for the war,
basically a general Washington was a
federalist.
Various other people,
generally people who were federalists in
this first sentence.
People who want to strengthen the
central government,
17,
seventies and eighties had either been
in Congress or they had been officers in
the military or some of them had been
diplomats.
So they saw that during the revolution
we,
I literally had American soldiers who
starved to death in the field,
went into battle literally without
muskets who,
uh,
in the winter,
didn't have boots and their feet broken,
bled a,
they didn't have blankets.
Um,
there were people who were diplomats
like John Jay and Thomas Jefferson who
went overseas and John Jay,
for example,
in the seventies and eighties when he
was American minister to Spain,
showed up in Spain.
And the first thing he had to ask the
foreign ministers assistant was,
can you loan me some money so I can buy
some food?
Wow,
I need to borrow money.
So I can get myself a place to sleep.
Um,
so in other words,
the federal government had no money.
I couldn't do anything.
And it also,
during the revolution it had not only
did it have to ask Congress for money to
pay for things,
but it had to ask,
I'm sorry,
did it have to ask the states to pay for
things?
But the,
the congress had to ask the states for
men and always they got less.
They have less money than they had asked
for.
They had less,
fewer men than they had asked for.
And there were some times when states
said,
no,
we're not sending anything.
So by the time the Philadelphia
convention met in 17,
87,
every single state had sometimes sent
less than requested.
Some of them had sent nothing in some in
response to some of these requests from
men or money.
And was there a punishment?
What can we do?
There was no as if,
as if today,
for example,
we have this situation of president
trump made famous in 2016 campaign in
which we have 27 members of NATO and
only five of them meet the two percent
of GDP threshold of,
of,
uh,
military spending that they have all
committed to what can the other 22 of
including the Americans who pay more
than anybody,
what can the rest of us do to Germany or
the Netherlands or Spain for not
spending two percent of GDP on the
military?
And the answer is nothing.
There's nothing we can do.
The same thing was going on and actually
the worst a transgressor in this regard
was Rhode Island,
which repeatedly sent nothing.
And these guys were the real rebels.
They were scofflaws and actually they
were going to send,
they were the only state that didn't
send anybody to the Philadelphia
convention because they didn't want to
strengthen it.
We're not paying.
Why should we want a straight from that?
That would mean we'd have to pay.
And they actually,
there were,
what economists call a free rider.
They realized that if Massachusetts,
Pennsylvania,
Virginia,
we're going to defend themselves,
they're going to be defending Rhode
Island.
Yeah,
so why should we pay for this?
So anyways,
so people like Washington who had been
commander and chief of the army and seen
his men in these dire straits in the
field and Madison who had been in
Congress and tried to get money to,
you know,
to send to Washington or men,
they realize this is inadequate.
We have to have something else.
So Madison drafted what's called the
Virginia plan,
which envisioned a new national
government,
unlike the one we have now,
unlike the one that was created by this
process.
So people credit him with having written
the constitution.
He wrote a rough draft that you could
say,
you know,
a couple of major features were made
part of a new constitution,
but many of the major features were
rejected over and over in.
Some of them met after he repeatedly
brought them up again.
And again,
when they get to the last week of the
Philadelphia Convention,
they voted on and one of his major pet
ideas and every single state including
Virginia voted no.
So he was not the author of the
Constitution.
It's not,
it's not true.
He played a very important role,
which should be remembered,
but I don't think it makes them look
better to make up something that he
didn't actually do.
So,
so interesting.
So this,
this group of federalist,
at the time they were really trying to
strengthen the federal government.
It sounds like it really was mostly for
military purposes.
I mean you mentioned the main function
for some overseas post.
Well you had to have diplomats.
If you're going to have a military,
you want to have diplomats overseas.
Mainly what the diplomats were doing was
trying to get alliances to help fight
the war,
to get foreign countries to loan the
United States money.
So it was all one cause essentially it
was about foreign policy.
That's what the federal government was
for.
This is classic federal government,
you know,
where you have some countries that can't
defend themselves,
and so they leave together for mutual
defense.
Yeah.
So,
all right,
so if he wasn't the author of the
Constitution in the way that we think,
what were the contributions that we need
to know about?
Well,
first he was one of the main people
behind the fact that there was a
Philadelphia convention.
So if there ended up being this meeting
have delegates from 12 states to talk
about amending the articles of
confederation so that the congress would
be able to raise men and money to,
you know,
send diplomats and raise an army.
Madison was one of the two or three
people most responsible for there being
a Philadelphia convention.
And then when they got to Philadelphia,
he persuaded the other Virginia
delegates who included some of the most
prominent men in the country,
uh,
to propose what's called the Virginia
plan,
which laid out that there should be
three branches of the federal
government,
that the legislature should be by
cameras.
It should have a taxing power.
These are very important ideas.
These are all the ideas that ultimately
made it into,
these are some ideas that ultimately
made it into the constitution at all.
These are important ideas that made it
in the constitution,
but.
But again,
if we had time,
I could go through many other ideas of
Madison proposed that were rejected.
In fact,
one of them.
Yeah.
Give me.
Give me one.
One example is madison proposed that
there should be three branches of a new
national government.
It should have a national legislature
and national executive under national
judiciary.
The national legislature should be by
camera.
Okay.
So far this sounds like the US
constitution so far.
I'm with you.
Okay,
so the lower house shall be elected by
the people.
The upper house shall be elected by the
lower house.
Both houses should be apportioned by
population.
The congress should have a veto overall
state laws that Congress should be able
to to legislate about anything they
wanted.
About half of what I just said is not in
the constitution,
including the veto overall state laws.
Madison said was his favorite proposal
really,
and it sounds so counter.
He thought it was essential for the
central government to be able to say,
if Rhode Island,
uh,
wants to print paper money,
no veto,
you can't print paper money.
So that was one thing.
So this must've been one of those points
that he and Jefferson had a major
difference,
right?
Well,
Jefferson was in France while the
constitution was being written,
so he only saw it afterward.
He couldn't have been thrilled.
Actually.
This is kind of funny because it's good
that you asked me this because when,
when Jefferson received the constitution
first,
the Philadelphia convention ends on
September 17,
17,
87.
And you have 11 states signed the
constitution.
Rhode Island never showed up,
so they didn't.
New York couldn't sign because two of
their three delegates had left.
So Hamilton signed it,
but he didn't.
He couldn't vote Yes for New York
because he was only one of three
delegates.
So he was not a quorum himself.
So 11 states sign it.
And then Madison waited from September
17th until October 24th to send
Jefferson a copy.
Usually two of them are writing each
other all the time.
He waits a month and a week before he
sends him a copy.
Why does he wait so long?
Well,
there are two parts of the answer.
One is he's writing a very long letter.
There are hundreds and hundreds of
surviving letters between the two of
them over the 50 year friendship.
Very long body of very large body of,
of missives,
back and forth,
but he waited a long time.
One thing he did was he wrote a
description of the convention,
which is several pages,
but another thing seems to been he
probably knew that Jefferson wasn't
going to like this thing,
so Jefferson,
by the time he got Madison's letter
cover letter in copy of the Constitution
has already received it from someone
else and then when he read it,
he,
he looked at it and he wrote to his
friend John Adams,
who in Britain,
Jefferson's and France.
Adams is in Britain.
So Jefferson sends Adam's a letter and
he says,
I've seen.
Have you seen the product of the
Philadelphia Convention?
I own that.
I'm,
I'm disappointed in the car in this.
I would have expected more from the
people who were in the Philadelphia
Convention.
I don't know.
I don't know whether it's more good or
more bad,
but.
So that's his original response to it.
And then when he finally gets it from
Madison he says,
okay,
I liked bicameralism and I liked that
Congress has a taxing power and I,
I liked that there was an independent
executive and you have a judiciary,
but there are a couple of things I don't
like.
One is perpetual eligibility of the
president.
That's terrible idea.
President will be able to make friends
all over the country.
He'll be able to hand out contracts and
make appointments and pretty soon a
president will serve for life.
This is a bad idea.
You should have a term limit.
He thought.
And the second thing was he says there's
no bill of rights.
So then he had madison.
This is one of the other areas where
they had a serious disagreement.
They went back and forth over this
question whether there should be a bill
of rights and Madison's answer was,
well,
okay,
um,
I like the principles you would include
in your bill of rights,
but the thing is,
um,
I don't think a bill of rights really is
going to bind anybody.
So over time the government will ignore
or violate or in some sense,
practically void the bill of rights.
And what will people learn from that?
So I think it's better that the people
should have their insistence on
particular rights and when they vote,
they should ensure that their
representatives stand for these,
right?
But if you don't want to put them in the
constitution,
and Jefferson says,
well,
okay,
it's true that occasionally that,
uh,
people who hold office will violate the
provisions of bill of rights.
But on the other hand,
it's something you can point to.
You can say,
this guy shouldn't be reluctant because
look,
fourth amendment,
he violated it.
He doesn't care about it all you should.
So they went back and forth and Madison
says,
well these,
you know,
in Virginia we have a declaration of
rights and it's ignored.
The legislature violates at Madison and
Jefferson says that's true,
but you and I are both complaining about
it and other people complain about it
too and we,
you know,
at least we can point to that.
Besides that,
Jefferson says,
I think a bill of rights has an
instructive.
It's got an educational function.
People maybe they don't think about
these kinds of questions and if he
didn't mention them to them,
they,
they might.
They might never come to mind for them.
But if you have a bill of rights
listing,
particular rights that people should be
able to count on,
then they'll realize that somebody is
violating one of their important rights
and then they'll care when otherwise
they would never notice.
So he says,
I think even if only for that a bill of
rights was good idea.
Madison comes back and says,
well,
yeah,
I think it would take a lot of work and
probably people are going to be really
disappointed if they think that we're
going to have to amend the Constitution
and Jefferson finally you can tell he
gets angry,
so at his answer to that is look,
Bill of rights is what the people are
entitled to against every government in
the world general or particular.
So by this point,
Madison has already gone to the
Philadelphia Convention.
He's worked through the whole
convention.
When they got to the end of it,
his friend George Mason and his friend
Edmund Randolph,
both from Virginia ones,
George the George Mason,
the leading constitutional thinker in
Virginia and the other one is at Miranda
off the governor of Virginia and former
attorney general of Virginia.
They both refused to sign it,
partly because it didn't have bill of
rights.
Now was Thomas Jefferson and
corresponding with them,
we don't know.
We don't know that he was in and I think
if he had been either here they would've
saved letters.
So I don't think so,
but the thing is.
But the thing is Jefferson insisting on
this follows on Mason and randolph
insisting on this and refusing to sign,
and you have to kind of imagine madison
thinking,
okay,
I don't think this is that important.
I don't really think it would have that
much impact,
but if it's going to mean that Mason
Randolph and Jefferson are opposed,
this could mean that we don't get the
thing ratified.
So finally he's going to say,
I agree to this.
Now,
one,
one thing you can rightly call Madison
is the author of the bill of rights.
But it's interesting to look at the way
he introduced this in Congress.
So they go to Congress after he's been
elected to Congress on the ground that
he put,
he promised he would seek amendments in
Congress.
And then when he finally introduces
these amendments,
here's how he introduces them.
He says,
you know,
some men who would otherwise be willed,
disposed toward our new government are
opposed to it because it doesn't have a
bill of rights.
And that he says this in his speech in
Congress and I don't think it can hurt
anything.
So why don't we add these,
right?
So he's not persuaded,
but he thinks it's a good political
idea.
So nowadays we think,
oh,
James Madison gave us,
you know,
the basis of every lawsuit in America.
No,
no,
he grudgingly did this because his
friends wanted him to.
And he was afraid they would never agree
to,
to support the constitution if he didn't
say,
okay,
we'll have these.
And he says,
I don't think they're going to hurt
anything,
please.
Let's agree to them.
We'll get,
you know,
we get people like Randolph and Mason
and Jefferson to be enthusiastic.
So basically he was a realist at that.
He was all the time a realist.
He in Jefferson kind of Yin and Yang
right once,
once,
kind of impractical,
theoretical,
philosophical.
He's very,
they're both very bookish.
We both know you can name 50 books and
political science in Greek and Latin
into English classics and a couple of
freshmen.
They both know every page,
right?
But they come out of this entirely
different and yet they're,
they're just very affectionate friends
because they have this common interests
and they both think,
well,
we have kind of the same goal.
We want Americans to be free.
What we want to republic,
we want stability,
we want prosperity,
we don't want wars.
They have a lot in common.
But I hope you've already gotten that.
They're very different.
Yeah,
well it's fascinating and it's like,
you know,
241 some odd years later,
the idea that Jefferson was pushing
their up.
We need people to be able to point to
something and say that's one thing that
actually does seem to work the time
because as everyone watching this knows,
I mean I'm constantly yammering about
free speech and the first amendment.
We know what the First Amendment is.
We know the second amendment is the
right to bear arms.
We know the fourth amendment is the
right to privacy.
I mean,
so that point really does seem like it's
something that truly translated over
time and that is,
it kind of had to be dragged into it.
So they had to be completely had to be
dragged into it.
In fact,
he also was defeated for election to the
first US Senate,
partly because of his having resisted
having a bill of rights in the
constitution.
That's why he ends up in the House of
Representatives.
So not only are people in Virginia who
didn't want a new constitution,
they didn't like Madison for having this
Philadelphia Convention and the rest of
it,
but they also were very skeptical about
his willingness to amend the
constitution.
So they kept him out of the Senate and
he ends up being narrowly elected.
The House of Representatives.
How much
fighting was there once they said,
okay,
well once he conceded the point on the
bill of rights,
how much writing was there as to what
actually was going to be in the bill of
rights?
Not a lot.
People weren't really interested because
the first congress was completely
dominated by federalists.
So you have most historians now who've
spent a lot of attention on the process
of creating the constitution.
In ratifying it.
Think probably most voters didn't want
it.
So if we had time to go through it state
by state and kind of talk about how it
came to be ratified,
I think I could persuade you that it
seems like most American voters did not
want the constitution it had to do with
better tactics on the side of the
federalists that it ended up being
agreed to.
Um,
so,
but what,
was there anything that once the bill of
rights was actually being written that
Jefferson and Madison or any of them had
read?
Like this has to be in here,
but we're not really fighting over any
of that?
Well,
several estates that had close
ratification contest with their
announcements.
We've ratified since proposed
amendments.
So at an early point after five states,
okay.
Philadelphia convention in September 17,
17,
87,
five states immediately ratified within
weeks for them were small states like
Rhode Island that new.
This is the sweetest table.
Everyday we're equal.
We're equal to fill to Virginia and in
Massachusetts,
in the Senate,
you know,
that means we're going to be heavier
than we ought to be in the electoral
college.
That means we're going to be having more
of a voice in choosing presidents and
judges and we better hurry up and agree
to this same thing happened in Georgia
and a couple of other small states
besides Pennsylvania,
which was an odd case.
Um,
but then the next state up,
the first big state that considered this
question was Massachusetts in there.
It wasn't clear who had more votes in
the convention of federalist or anti
federalists.
So finally,
the federalist society that,
right,
well,
we don't really know that we're going to
win here.
So maybe we could say if you will vote
for this thing,
we will promise in the first congress
will propose amendments.
So this became the kind of the
Massachusetts strategy.
So the later states that had close
contests did the same thing and that's
what Virginia did.
Madison's thing.
I don't really know whether we're going
to get.
We're going to get this thing ratified
in Virginia will promise in the first
congress will propose amendments.
So that's why he's doing this right?
It's not because we liked the idea,
but anyway,
several of the states that had these
clothes,
convention contests with their
announcements,
we've officially ratified the thing per
article seven also sent along here are
our proposed amendments,
so what Madison did was he took the
Virginia Declaration of Rights,
which we said earlier,
he helped to write and he took the
English bill of rights from 1689,
which was a kind of a pattern for some
of the other American declarations of
rights and he took these proposals from
various ratification conventions and
found most of what's now in the bill of
rights in those sources.
Right.
It's not as if he kind of made them up.
In fact,
the eighth amendment comes directly out
of the Virginia Declaration of Rights,
which got it directly from the English
bill of Rights of 16,
80 nine.
It's word for word the same thing.
Really?
Yeah.
The eighth amendment is directly from
the Virginia Declaration directly from
the English bill of rights.
All right,
so we've got obviously a ton here.
Lead it,
you know,
his whole life and all the work of
founding the nation that we're governed
by.
It's not done yet though.
No,
I know.
So let's talk a little bit about his
presidency since we're doing presidents
week.
What's the most important thing we need
to know about?
Well,
this is the worst part of his career.
It's,
it's his foreign policy is a debacle.
In fact,
he had the idea in the early seventies
and eighties that America could some
extent substitute economic coercion for
traditional military,
uh,
calculations in international relations.
So he persuaded Jefferson,
for example,
in Eighteen,
oh,
seven,
they could adopt an embargo instead of
building up the military,
raising taxes,
buying warships,
defending American merchant ships off
the coast of the United States.
Now we'll just tell foreigners,
okay,
if you won't,
if you won't treat us right at sea,
we won't trade with you.
This will make them do what we want.
And that the reason he had this idea was
because it had worked before the
revolution in 17,
65,
17,
67,
17 slash 70.
The British past tax laws and the
colonies boycotted.
And they repeal the laws,
so madison thinks,
well,
okay,
now we're better able to organize,
but it can be a national boycott will
use the government to keep any Americans
from trading with foreigners.
They'll do what we want.
But the problem he had an 18,
12 was there was a world war going on.
Napoleon has armies of 3 million men in
the field,
which today,
you know,
it doesn't sound like much.
We have 325 million Americans.
3 million is more than we have,
but we can have them if we wanted.
But on the other hand,
in 18,
12 francis population was like $25
million.
It was the biggest country in Europe.
Britain had like 15 million people,
3 million men in the army was
unbelievable.
And Britain had over 500 warships,
right?
Main line warships like the dreadnoughts
in the pirates of the Caribbean movies.
Right?
So America is not going to compete.
Madison thought,
well then we shouldn't even try.
We should just say we're not going to
trade with you.
And so they tried when he was secretary
of state under Jefferson,
they tried this boycott idea.
It had no effect at all on the French,
on the British.
France had complete military control of
Europe and Britain had complete control
of all the oceans and it was a battle to
the death.
If the polling,
we're able to cross channel,
he would conquer England,
right?
If the British wanted to defend
themselves,
they had to maintain their navy.
How are they going to do that?
Well,
one way was they were going to continue
to force people into their navy if they
thought there were Britain's in American
ships,
they were going to force them into the
Royal Navy.
And the other thing was they weren't
going to let the United States trade
with France.
They weren't gonna let Americans carry
products from British of,
I'm sorry,
from French colonies in the Caribbean to
France or anywhere else in Europe.
And on the other hand,
the French policy was,
we're not going to let the Americans
trade with Europe because they're
trading with the British.
Yeah.
So both neither France nor Britain could
be,
could possibly be persuaded to give up
it's Po,
it's a strategy in this world,
war with the other,
because it was to the death.
But what the US government could do was
it can wreck America,
which is what it did.
This was terrible.
The war of 18,
12 following this boycott.
The boycott was an economic disaster in
the United States and then comes,
okay,
we're going to declare war.
Well,
one of the leading spokesman for
republicanism,
old Jeffersonian Thinking was a
congressman from Virginia named John
Randolph of Roanoke,
and when this idea of war with Britain
came up,
he said,
you're going to go to war with Britain.
We don't have any warships where we have
no money.
What are you talking?
Are you kidding?
This is impossible.
And of course the.
The result was they burned down the
capital.
They burned down the White House.
They burn a library of Congress,
they bring the war department.
They burned the State Department.
They bring the Treasury Department.
That's just madison has to hop on a
horse and ride out of DC.
This is totally predictable,
is not only predictable,
it was predicted,
so this is a disaster and the only
reason it didn't lead to the end of the
United States is because the British
decided it's not really worth the
effort.
So at one point the prime minister of
the United Kingdom went to the greatest,
a British general ever,
the Duke of Wellington.
This was before waterloo,
but he was already the greatest general
British history and he said to him,
I,
okay,
so I give you an army and I send you to
North America.
And Wellington says,
well then I conquered the United States
and then what we're going to stay there
going to occupy the country were good as
that.
So yeah.
So then the prime minister says,
well,
okay,
then we'll negotiate a piece so that it
was just a complete debacle.
You could not exaggerate the extent to
which this is a mess.
The people really didn't know many
people who write about Madison though
they want.
And again,
this is a pitfall that biographers tend
to fall into.
You know,
I'm writing about this guy,
so he's my hero.
What can I say that's good about him?
Well,
the one thing you can say that's good
about Madison is a war president.
I mean,
he's.
He.
His strategy was terrible.
He picked totally inept in competent,
unqualified people to be his war
secretary and he's navy secretary.
He just did a terrible job.
Is as a military leader,
but the one thing you can say about him
is he didn't repress descent.
He didn't jail people.
He didn't have the army attack a militia
units in states that were,
by this time openly trading with the
British.
He didn't put down domestic dissension
the way that Lincoln did,
or Wilson did,
or you know,
that's interesting though,
so I didn't know that.
So states we're actually just bucking
with.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
In New England,
people were trading with Canada,
which was part of the British empire,
but the New England was talking about
independent,
so we should declare independence.
There were leading people including a
felony and pickering who was a senator
by this time.
He had been secretary of state under
Washington.
He says,
new English would be an independent
country,
were rightly,
we should be aligned with the British,
not with this pro French Republican
policy that Jefferson and Madison have
wrecked our economy with.
There's no reason for this.
So the argument that the,
uh,
sick of fence of,
of Madison make as well,
Lincoln would have jail.
These people,
he would have wrecked their presses.
This is what he did.
Or Wilson,
he would've jail all these people,
you know,
he would have sent the army and shot
militia units that were resisting
American policy.
So yeah.
Okay.
You can say that,
right?
The burden of the Capitol,
the White House Treasury state,
but at least he didn't.
He didn't hang dissenters.
Wow.
There's.
So,
it was a terrible though the again,
the only reason that the United States
continue to exist was because Britain
decided,
eh,
it's not worth the effort that we could
easily.
Wellington's said,
yeah,
I conquer them.
Then what?
Yeah.
It's just a great line.
I mean,
that's the truth.
Nobody thinks that the then what he
thinks about it.
All right.
My final question for you,
I mean this has been really chock full
of,
of Info here because we're doing
presidents week weekend,
I'm doing five different presidents and
in five different days in the 2018 lens,
what do you think James Madison's
political outlook would be because it's
interesting they all sort of in the lens
of now they all sort of look like
Libertarians and small government
people.
But you have said several things here
where he wanted a stronger federal
government.
I know it's a kind of tricky question
because it,
because our parties are so crazy right
now and everything else,
but if you can give you some sense of
where he might fall now or what he might
think these days.
Well,
I don't think they're all libertarians.
I don't think Washington or at Hamilton
is a libertarian today.
Um,
but I do think people like Jefferson and
Madison to the extent that you can kind
of extrapolate from what they thought
then,
which they're a foreboding about the
result of a foreign policy.
Like the one we've had has proven
justified.
Of course,
we have huge economic distortions
because of our,
our,
uh,
foreign policy,
we have a gigantic,
a remaking of the nature of our
governments and we have huge diminution
of the role of the average citizen in
making his own life or shaping his own
community are.
And so it's turned out kind of the way
they thought it might in that sense.
On the other hand,
the fact that the union has proven
stable,
the,
the main freedoms have been enduring.
This is somewhat surprising.
People thought that,
and this had been true,
republican isn't with short lived,
there never been a long lasting
significant republic.
And so we still have a republic,
even if it has a lot of the elements
that people like Jefferson and Madison
and wanted to forestall or prevent it
still republican.
We have freedom of speech,
we have freedom of religion,
we have input into what the policies
are,
the government,
even if it's somewhat attenuated.
And so,
uh,
I think Jefferson would be more
disappointed,
but Jefferson was disappointed by the
time he died,
but I think he'd be more disappointed
than Madison surely.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's a really interesting takeaway and
I think a perfect point edits.
I've thoroughly enjoyed this.
I mean,
Richard is acknowledge you just gave me
a book.
There's a lot of stuff I'm going to have
to go back in and think about,
so thank you so much for more of Kevin's
work,
you can check out James Madison and the
making of America,
which will link to write down below.